traditionnellement la musique
électronique c'est une musique qui est
composé en studio par des humains mais
qui après est joué par les machines et
nous ce qu'on a essayé de faire avec
helmut lobby c'est d'inverser cette
dynamique et de faire des des logiciels
et des instruments qui pourraient d'une
certaine façon composer la musique pour
laisser tout le fun à l'humain et le fun
il est dans l'interprétation rugby on a
été bon s'est constitué en 2002 sur une
frustration c'est la frustration quand
vous êtes un musicien électronique et
que vous allez sur scène là ça ressemble
à ça le public ce qu'ils voient c'est un
laptop avec une pomme qui brille dans le
noir il sait pas si vous êtes en train
de jouer à call of duty ou si vous êtes
en train de faire la musique que vous
êtes en train de lire mais et c'est là
c'est assez frustrant et en tant que
musicien électronique le musette ceux
qui ont fondé un reboot lobby au départ
il avait déjà des carrière derrière eux
et dans sa carrière il avait il est à
vis du fait de leur production musicale
il était invité sur scène et ne se
sentait pas à l'aise n'avaient pas leur
place
or certains musiciens vont chercher les
artifices pour pouvoir faire baisser
cette tension de se créer de la
diversion sur scène en se déguisant en
mettant peut-être des feux d'artifice
derrière eux ou des choses comme ça est
ce que ce qu'on a essayé de faire avec
helmut lobby c'est de créer des
instruments qu'on allait pouvoir aller
jouer pour les défendre de la musique
électronique en live vraiment comme
n'importe le ferait n'importe quel autre
type de musiciens en dix ans plus tard
un concert des boucles au but à
ressemble à ça je suis émerveillé de
voir
deux personnes partagent avec mon coeur
[Musique]
toutes choses qui se passent dans cette
vidéo vous voyez on a une vraie batterie
on a augmenté avec des capteurs et les
capteurs ne vont pas rajouter des sons
sur la batterie ils vont avoir un impact
sur ce que le papier le bassiste est en
train de jouer le bacille autres
adjoints qu'une manette de playstation 3
les notes qu'il a accessible sur cette
déception droits sont en fait contrainte
parce qu est en train de jouer pascal
avec les pas des nae joystick et leçons
d'abbas est contraint parce que la
batterie est en train de jouer par
exemple si le batteur d'étape sur la
grosse caisse
le bassiste à une basse électrique si le
batteur joue sur la lac est clair le
bassiste akbar sa boutique et ça c'est
le genre de le genre de magie qu'on a
développé ses les outils qu'on a
développée pour permettre à des
performeurs qui n'étaient pas des plates
formes en au départ de le devenir et
d'aller défendre leur projet sur cède le
on apprendra appelé système le wild time
systémique music frameworks et non un
peu un peu barbare comme ça mais en fait
assez simple il ya trois concepts de
base qui sont le fait que tout est en
réelle si on touche pas les instruments
les instruments de joue pas tout seul
les instruments sont expressifs parce
que les instruments de musique
électronique ou son ne l'ont pas
toujours été ne le sont pas toujours
donc c'est à dire qu'on veut pouvoir
faire passer de l'émotion faire passer
de l'attention à travers l'instrument et
pour ça il faut que l'instrument puisse
répondre à des petites variations et pas
juste être un bouton qui est on off
c'est tout cas donc ça c'est le deuxième
axe et d'expressivité le troisième c'est
la systémique systémique est un tout
petit peu plus compliqué mais pas
tellement plus donc si vous avez un
groupe de rock classique vous avez une
guitare une basse une batterie
les trois vont jouer et vont interagir
ensemble au niveau des musiciens les
musiciens pour ses coûteuses répondre et
et vont jouer différemment en fonction
de ce que les autres sont en train de
jouer et à la fin on va mixer tous et
l'envoyer dans une sono ou sur un disque
la musique systémique les instruments se
parle aussi et c'est sale et ses
relations entre le batteur qui a une
influence sur la base sur la basse et le
claviériste qui a une influence aussi
sur la basse ça c'est la systémique
musicale et c'est ce serait mort
systémique il est composé de plein de
petits blocs techniques c'est des
petites briques conceptuel qui sont
assez simple c'est des petits logiciels
ou des petits
des petits morceaux de d'électronique et
je vais vous en présenter deux mais il
en existe plein d'autres le premier
c'est celui-ci c'est le big fail
[Musique]
le professeur il est particulièrement
intéressant parce que c'est il fait
partie d'une d'un type de détournement
qu'on a fait qu'on a fait d'orner moi et
m'ont énormément on a pris deux
instruments qui existait dans le sur le
marché ça ce sont des espèces de jouer
pour eux pour dj sont même pas de très
bonne qualité mais qui sont faits pour
la diffusion
c'est fait pour pouvoir jouer des
disques durs dans des fêtes
d'anniversaire mais en fait quand on
regarde de façon plus abstraite succès
s'est jamais que des des contrôles
électroniques qui vont envoyer des
signaux à l'ordinateur et l'ordinateur à
les interpréter
nous on a transformé ce et ses outils
qui était fait pour la diffusion et on
en a fait des outils qui sont vous fait
pour la performance avec le beat feuz
d'heure en fait vous déplacez le curseur
de gauche à droite
et quand vous atteignez certain point
sur la course du soir ou du curseur vous
déclenchez des notes sous c'est
relativement simple comme comme outil
mais c'est très puissant
un deuxième une deuxième brique de spray
mois requis celle que le canton est
comme son nom l'indiqué bien c'est juste
un compteur en fait ce qu'il va faire ce
qui va compter les impulsions les
événements par exemple le nombre de
frappes sur la grosse caisse et puis va
donner un ordre fonction doit quand il
atteint certain nombre par exemple si je
joue trois fois la grosse caisse la
prochaine caisse claire aime sa balle
bonus aussi je joue trois fois la grosse
caisse leçons de la base va changer ça
c'est le un autre un autre élément dans
une autre brique conceptuelle du fresnoy
qu'il y en a encore plein d'autres
et quand on met tout ça ensemble
juste passer ça quand on met tout ça
ensemble on se retrouve avec un système
qui ressemble à ça ou on a mis des
compteurs sur les beats fader les beats
fender on les a mis sur des surfaces
tactiles avec de xy réduit parfois de la
pression on a mis un joystick avec un
pitch bend magique c'est à dire que
c'est comme modèle depuis deux semaines
sur le côté des claviers mais plutôt que
d'aller à la prochaine note de la porte
et il va aller à la prochaine date de la
gamme donc vous êtes toujours toujours
juste et on bricole comme ça c'est
encore une autre à d autres d autres
modules et on en a quand je vous dis
place et une fois qu'on a eu terminé de
jouer avec ça pour nous parce qu'au
départ c'était quelque chose qu'on a
fait pour nos propres besoins scénique
on s'est rendu compte qu'on pouvait
l'utiliser également dans la perspective
de permettre à des gens qui n'ont pas de
bagages musicaux ou qui n'ont pas
l'opportunité de pratiquer leur
instrument de d'avoir ce plaisir de
l'interprétation musicale et on a créé
playground les plaies grande c'est
l'application vous avez vu tout à
l'heure c'est en fait un condensé de
tout c'est de tout le framework mis dans
une application mobile
et puis on en a fait une version que
vous avez vu sur une grande table
tactile et qui permet de jouer en fait
tous les instruments en une fois en
glissant son doigt sur l'écran
vous êtes toujours juste vous êtes
toujours plus ou moins dans le temps
pouvait faire des trucs plus ou moins
beaux en fonction de votre compétence
mais vous pourrez jamais de faire un
truc qui est complètement moche mais
c'est la magie les grains ici c'est une
map en afrique alta qui sera aux
ardentes et si c'était moi je vous
conseille fortement d'aller écouter
leurs albums se sert des meilleurs
albums de rap que j'ai entendu cette
année quoi belle d'opinion y en a fait
une autre une autre version on avait
déjà vu la grande table avait déjà vu
sur le téléphone on en a fait une
troisième version qui est probablement
la plus grande à ce jour on l'a fait sur
une rampe de skateboard et là c'est
exactement le même principe que le
que sur l'iphone sur l'ipad
sauf qu'on a remplacé la surface tactile
par la rampe de skate et votre le doigt
est remplacé par le losc est d'ordre
c'est lui qui tout est joué en direct
c'est lui qui joue tout quoi j'ai passé
à la vidéo suivante avant qu'il tombe ce
que je connais la vidéo que je vous
parlais d'expression d'augmenter
l'expressivité du bit fadeur tout à
l'heure mais je voulais pas raconter
l'histoire du bide fadeur le bit fadeur
en fait c'est vous savez quand les
rappeurs chante il faut y bouge leurs
mains dans l'espace sur le rythme et
c'est le jour il y avait un rapport qui
était au studio il était en train de
rapper et il bouge ça m'a il y avait une
table de mixage devant lui du coup ils
bougent le fadeur sur le rythme de ce
qu'il est en train de rapper et puis ils
arrêtent et il dit ce serait super si je
pouvais faire le bide comme ça
directement en jouant sur le fan de rap
quart d'heure plus tard il y avait un
prototype fonctionnel un petit bout de
software qui permettait de faire ça et
le et c'était il ya des années et puis
quelques années il ya trois ans
maintenant quatre ans on était aux
musiques techfest cours à caton et on
s'est dit on va pousser ce truc-là plus
loin et on va lui permettre de lobby de
fadeur de jouer aussi des basslines et
pour jouer les bassline on a augmenté
l'expressivité du bit fadeur c'est à
dire on met des capteurs sur le capuchon
en plastique qui permet de bouger le
curseur et quand on le presse on envoie
un nouveau contrôle qui va déclencher
les bass line et c'est comme ça qu'est
né le contrôle cap est maintenant un
produit de conques on vend et qu'on a un
petit peu rires réorienter vers un
public qui est plus apte à exploiter
vraiment son potentiel c'est à dire les
dj du monde du hip hop qui font du
scratch parce que les scratcheurs ont
une main sur le vinyle une main sur le
crossfader et s'ils veulent ouvrir en
effet ou faire quoi que ce soit d'autre
ils sont obligés de couper la phrase sur
laquelle il se trouve et donc on s'est
dit on plutôt que de les obliger à la
chelle fadeur pour aller tourner un
bouton on va mettre le bouton dans
l'oeuf adore comme ça ils ont plus
besoin de bouger leur mac et voilà le
contrôle cap et vous allez voir sur la
vidéo
on voit petit bout d'interface en
dessous vous voyez les contrôles des
effets il quand ils pressent sur le
faire sur le bouton du fadeur les effets
souvent vous appris quelques temps
d'arriver à miniaturiser tous et à le
vendre suffisamment autonome et sans fil
du match et tout ça mais bref on bien
non il existe de fait encore une
dernière petite vidéo que j'ai envie de
vous montrer parce qu'elle est elle est
particulièrement belle va de mon point
de vue de deux développeurs de
l'application plus grande
c'est un dj de los angeles qui s'appelle
de requêtes qui nous l'a envoyé il ya
quelques jours est en fait il reprend
plusieurs maps de playground et il fait
un nouveau morceau avec plutôt que de
remixes et une seule map il en a
[Musique]
et pour nous qui avons passé beaucoup de
temps à détourner des instruments qui a
été proposée par d'autres c'est vraiment
fait très plaisir de voir à nos
utilisateurs qui détournent notre
instrument pour au service de sa
créativité aussi vous ça vous intéresse
d'aller plus loin et d'explorer ce qu'on
fait je vous conseille d'aller voir le
site web
on est sur les réseaux sociaux est
évidemment un peu partout et le
l'application plus grande est gratuite
elle est sur l'app store sont
malheureusement il n'existe que pour
eiris donc ses iphone ipad mais elle a
été téléchargée plus de 500 millions de
fois
le cinq cent mille fois excusez moi à
deux millions c'est à demi million que
je voulais dire plus d'un million de
fois et là et voilà j'espère qu'elle
vous plaira autant que nous plaît
qu'elle plaît à plat d'utilisateurs
merci
[Applaudissements]